Tropic Thunder I had two things I just
want to touch on with it um the first
you working with Robert Downey jr. in
blackface as a method actor back then
that movie was I mean still funny but
I'm saying back then it was not like now
with Trump in office if he was red right
now as I showed you our polarizing oh
yeah let's go so quickly
mmm-hmm yeah Emily what ales great great
experience but then we would not have
would not work right now it's a they
right now but did you ever get did you
ever get offended or like I mean you
just sing like a white kind blackface
you know funny because I did grow up
thinking that we're all equal you know
so for me it wasn't offensive I thought
it's like fun but then Austin I did the
history of blackface also wait a minute
you know it's offense I was twenty two
hundred a film you weren't thinking
about right kids don't see race like
that you know they don't see different
nations like that I guess when you get
older you get programs right start to
see nations and there's certain Wayne I
do believe every nation is different
every nation has their greatness to it
and but at the time I wasn't saying it
and I was trying to have fun you know no
history oh my wait a minute what do you
mean you people you know me so that's
where that line came from I start to
kind of like look what do you mean you
like what do you mean me that line was
like an improv and he was just walking
around set like that right what about
being under the the helm of Ben Stiller
like what was that a great college I
think that was a college oh yeah that
was a great college for me so I learned
a lot from Ben and I told Ben I was like
Ben I learned so much for me nobody's
negro let me stop hope i redeemed too
much I never forget the face yeah like
Ben I learned so much from he was like
yeah great so just how he is like he's
nah nah he cool I'm just being stupid
kind of looking at me like did you I
think it was a stress though the
90,000,000 are moving right explosions
going on I'm having a hot breath eh we
out cheer shout out
Pontus water yes yeah that's her that's
the sponsor really doing blue mountain
spring water that's good Hey give you a
breath one breath at a time so what did
you specifically learn from him from Ben
I mean he's great filmmaking he's a
filmmaker Ben's record people know him
as an actor he's a filmmaker
concentrator very hard to do so he like
specifics about like his work ethic or I
think is amazing it's a plan an aerial
unreal but your honor you're on a 90
million dollar movie like this isn't
Roll Bounce you know like this is a
tough movie to believe in that I'm not
you know really being on rollerskates
but but 90 million like you're looking
at them you're looking at like
blockbuster yeah most people on the
planet don't even get to be on set for
something like that yeah so even like
yeah it was it was a great great ride
man I'm starting to learn that you can
do I learned that you could do more with
less - you don't need 90 million - to do
90 million quality movies you just need
a great writer great producer that are
that's humble and want to make films
so the 90 million is like the hype like
90 million other comedy yeah and that
was big back then nowadays I mean I
guess more noise not even not a comedy
still don't exist nothing about it still
doesn't exist so yeah good times
I breath